I'll begin by distributing these coefficients to what's inside the parentheses
on either side of the equation. Now that I've done that, we have very pretty
integer coefficients. And we don't have to worry about fractions at all. Now
I'll get all the variables on the left side of the equation, and then I'll move
all the constants over to the right. Last, I just divide by 4, or of course,
equivalently, multiply by 1/4. And we get a final answer of x equals negative 22
over 4. But wait, this is not a fraction in simplest form. Both 22 and 4 are
divisible by 2, so I can cancel those 2's out, and I end up with negative 11
over 2. So that, in fact, is the correct answer, x equals negative 11 over 2. I
can look back at the top and plug this in to check. And in the end, I get
negative 21 equals negative 21, so we are good to go with this answer. Awesome
job.
Just as a side note, you also could have written several other equivalent things
for our answer, -11 over 2. You could have had negative 5 1/2, or you could also
have written negative 5.5. Any of those three are correct.